i got to talk about this podcast because
i you know me i every now and then i
find something i just can't stop
watching yeah and i mean i've only
showed you a few minutes of this but it
is the greatest thing i've ever seen in
my life i can't believe it even exists
it is the most la thing i've ever seen i
like these people i don't know them but
they're they're
they're fun
and this is not a knock on them at all
this is the most la
thing i have ever watched in my life
these are three influencers trying to
explain kind of what an influencer is
yeah and what an influencer does
it's very interesting to watch this
and it makes me laugh
hard in a world where nothing does
anymore this really entertains me
because it's kind of i don't know if
it's a genuine
or if it's kind of a character or if
it's half genuine or half character
it's hard to know but all i know here's
where i stop it's entertaining
very
entertaining this show
that i watch
uh and and i watched their breakdown of
the russia
thing which was brilliant it was oh
really well they didn't know where
russia was
they didn't know what it was
and they didn't know what the ukraine
was
and it was such a refreshing perspective
versus everyone on twitter who's like an
expert in foreign policy in their own
heads these people
were brave enough to go i don't know
what that is
what is the ukraine
let's start there because by the way
that's a better system
in terms of figuring out what's going on
in the world to just start at ground
zero and go what is russia
go
i want to watch this little clip these
are three influencers explaining what it
is
to be an influencer it is truly one of
the greatest things i've ever seen
recommend it highly it's hard to avoid
the question yeah yeah like okay okay
let's see someone says someone hasn't
asked me that in so long also so that
should um
i'll just be like i don't know i'm just
like a lazy piece of [ __ ] and then i ran
away yeah
i don't i never i like it goes back and
forth between like i work in social
media which does which is not
like that doesn't make sense yeah
you do
yeah but like i feel like when you say
like i work in social media people are
thinking like behind the scenes like you
work for instagram kind of i don't know
but
i know i know i mean
yeah well i mean
[Laughter]
oh i say i do consulting and then no one
ever asks another question right
you could you could you could because
everybody consults
you know like
you can talk
i guess in a way actually what does
consulting mean it means to offer your
services pause that for a minute or
advice it's just
great it's informative what is
consulting
it's a great she the woman asked a
question hey what is what is that i
hadn't thought about that in a while
this is what's great about these people
they're unashamed to just go what is
console i don't know what it is
i hear it
people do it
but i don't know what it is they're just
pure salt of the earth it's just
kind of amazing
here and watch this because now they
they credit the one and these two credit
the one in the middle for i believe
inventing comedy on the internet
they
credit her for investing
no i'm not kidding around the the next
thing is they credit uh this woman in
the middle
for starting
comedy on the internet
i swear to god during the pandemic it's
breathtaking
i can't
i'm telling you right now
if this
is scripted
it is brilliant
or even if it's not scripted if it's
loosely verite style kirby enthusiast i
don't know what this is i don't know if
they know what it is but i'm telling you
right now i don't know any of you you
are doing
the greatest level of satire that maybe
has been done in the last decade i don't
know if you know what you're doing
but god don't stop please don't stop
let's go
in one way or another he's not a
consultant i said i used to say i work
in advertising because i thought like
okay with brands marketing marketing
advertising that checks out to me that
makes complete sense
people would ask me more about like what
agency and then well then if you think
about mute we're writers directors yeah
we are editors edit producers
we're writers directors editors
producers
where we're
entrepreneurs yeah
we're on tours yeah we're venture
capitalists
i mean we're writers we're directors
we're producers and again
no shade to anybody here but literally
they're going like this yeah
send
that's kind of what it is right right
are you like stuffing cheerios in their
mouth and like farting and
and then hitting send like but she's
going for writers we're directors we're
producers
she said she hadn't left her bed in like
a month yeah she's making it all from a
bed
from a bed she's a writer a director a
producer she's a gaffer she's she's the
terence malik of tickets she's the
martin scorsese it's amazing
she's like when you think about it
it's great she goes when you think about
it it's all in the words because when
you think about it we're writers
directors
actors
produce first of all
give them give them give them
give them writers oddly
give them
actors
okay even maybe give them directors
producers
they're producing
i guess they're producing the whole
yeah i don't know they're not making a
bunch of calls and organizing i don't
know but what's great is that they've
we've already established they don't
really know what words mean they go
what's a consultant so they don't know
what words really mean
and that's what makes it so good because
people that know what words mean are
boring i truly believe this and mean
this you're right when you don't know
what words mean you're anything
you know she's like i'm an invertebrate
zoologist
i'm a writer i'm an actress i'm an
astronaut [ __ ] what is she goes oh what
is an astronaut and they go i think it's
someone that like goes to other planets
and she goes oh
oh maybe i'm not that like so they don't
they have to like reverse engineer right
so let's now this is my favorite part
where these guys uh tell this woman in
the front in the middle that she started
they basically call her the charlie
chaplin no she's internet comedy she
started comedy on the internet which his
site was unaware and i'm sure she's a
lovely woman but again it's this is the
it's the best show on it's funnier than
my show it is funny it's not even close
it is not even a contest of how better
this is than what i do
we are our own agents yeah managers do
you guys like what we're doing so far
[Laughter]
do your parents do your parents feel
like we obviously like make videos
courtney i don't know if we said average
fashion blogger yeah better known online
as average fashion blogger we have her
in today it's one of our good friends
but like
let's break it down do your parents get
what you do
my parents yeah my dad's been obsessed
he like
he does it less now um but in the
beginning he like always called me like
i have a really really good viral video
for you yeah and they would say like the
most problematic thing in the world but
he like he gets it he like wants to do
it so bad i feel like you are really
like the blueprint you started off
that's really dramatic no i really mean
that with my whole heart like you
you started making comedic videos on
instagram i can't really think of
anyone that did it i think anyone that
made videos period before tick tock
right was like he goes i can't think of
anyone that made videos hold on roll
that one back because i can't think of
anyone that made videos before take like
it's a joke
you started making comedic videos on
instagram i can't really think of he's
kidding anyone that did it i think
anyone that made videos period before
tick tock right was the blueprint
yeah yeah yeah okay um and now you're
about to hit a million on tech talk she
already babe i already did
where the hell have you been no one told
me um all right
um
stunning
beautiful
i mean it's brilliant in a way um it's
brilliant in a way
because you have three people that are
influencers are trying to be influencers
whatever that means
trying to explain what it is
figuring out that it's kind of hard to
explain
with words
and
you know they're just kind of it's just
it's la this is l.a these are people are
just floating around
in in in in and out of reality
they're all like 14 years old they're
very young but they're not the other
thing is i don't know if they're 14 or
if they're like 40. i think they look
through no one knows yeah they're
supposed to look young they're supposed
to look i think they're supposed to
exude like a prepubescent yeah the whole
thing's like it's cartoonish and it
looks fun and it's like we're hanging
out like hanging out we're like
hanging out like you are like
like you're like a friend of ours like
you like
like remember that i met you like i met
you like
in a car
we're in a car what's a car
yeah so like
it's a it's a like it's like a spaceship
on the ground
and
and like remember coachella is like
really funny because like you were like
and and i was there and like we didn't
even know that we like we like knew each
other from like social media but like we
didn't like we didn't know
each other
so and then every now and then the brook
one will come in and she'll be like my
grandmother was in the holocaust
like out of nowhere and i'm like this is
the greatest show that's ever been done
no
[Music]
and she'll be like but she survived
and then
she'll be like was dozie cat good
at coachella
did you enjoy doji cat anyway
super fan of this show no it's lit
literally and my first show that i loved
the ww bro podcast was about a guy who
was 600 pounds and gave diet advice yes
nothing better yeah and he would be
great because he would come on and he
would go like he'd go thanksgiving i
take the day off he goes thanksgiving i
eat
and it was so beautiful